et vous l'avez vu et constaté l'été est
enfin là c'est le moment de profiter des
activités à 2 plein air à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines on
a inauguré aujourd'hui un nouvel espace
événementiel le village sportif installé
dans l'espace de l'ancienne piscine à
vagues il a ouvert ses portes pour
accueillir des jeunes du centre de
loisirs de 11 à 17 ans et propose de
nombreuses activités avec de nouveaux
équipements il est ouvert jusqu'au 9
août 9 août les précisions recueillies
par patrick graeff de dixmude à une
multitude d'activités donc qui sont soit
en activité libre on fait du prêt de
matériel ou soit des activités encadrées
avec donc des
diplômé d'état notamment sur différentes
activités telles que du flag rugby du
sport de plage
s'emballe du badminton on a des
nouveautés comme l'archerie tag qui est
une activité avec
des arcs notamment on a plutôt pas mal
de monde effectivement les créneaux sont
déjà bien préremplie eux
actuellement pratiquement l'ensemble des
journées sont couvertes à hauteur de 80%
en termes de créneaux